I know of the devil are you welcome to
PlayStation grenade today is the release
date of the first DLC for spider-man on
ps4 so I thought we'd go through it and
play it together just the Commission's
oh the heist comes with turf war and
silver lining coming soon I'm told that
these three DLCs are all one combined
story so part one will feed into DLC -
and you get a you get the idea let's do
this Mary Jane Watson associate editor
begin research notes my sources are
saying the mozzie is mounting a comeback
the old crime families were all but
wiped out until Fisk went away and they
started filling the void and the old
Don's were working harmoniously for
years but now that there's a power
vacuum there's bound to be a power
struggle it's only a matter of time
before one of the families makes a move
on the others better follow up with my
sources in the force hopefully we can
stop this crime comeback before it even
starts
[Music]
okay so it's nighttime in this verse DLC
this is fine for us hey Pete I'm working
on a story you might be interested in
mm-hmm the Oscorp expose expose a new
one it's about the Maggio crime families
the Cosa Nostra is making a comeback I
love it when you talk dirty sure one of
the dogs have this lost masterpiece
painting called the Maria and now
they're displaying it over at Manhattan
mocha and and I have a source who says
one of the families is planning to steal
it back tonight sounds like there's more
to it than just art appreciation we'll
swing by the Museum okay so that's the
setup there's something going to be
stolen and we jump into action simple as
that which means black cats is going to
be stealing it from under our very
fingers we'll get our love struck like
he always does and she'll get away
there we go you don't have to watch the
next 90 minutes or whatever I haven't
played for quite a while but the
swinging feels so damn good you forget
how well-made this game is you really do
MJ looks like your source was right
there's a small army of goons trying to
break in stay on the line while I take a
closer look just be careful if those
guys are mafia they play for keeps
hurry up come on boss wants that
painting we should have been in and out
by now
you want to try be my guest sheesh some
people will do anything to avoid paying
full price admission let's see if I can
still fight right ah three okay there's
that scam danger means somebody else can
see them
safe and safe now we can grab know he's
date are just stuff it
again right circles don't you know one
is to smash dig yes here we go let's
just have fun with this it's so well
made the combat is absolutely brilliant
you can't hit me my soup caldo should
allow me to regen the folk focus that's
what scholars Nick focus metre focus bah
yeah I remember it is still bloody
brilliant I've only had of two weeks
that's two weeks you do forget this song
the new sure of it all the tiny little
things feel so good
non-fatal the history some 150 metres
across across concrete that man is not
going to survive and he's belted him in
the skull he doesn't hurt anyone ever I
know some of these guys that's the
Frederico frezelli right why would he
want the Maria it doesn't seem like his
thing I'm gonna look around make sure no
one got in a different way the cast is
someplace you know the painting going
what's your guess I think there's
something in the painting maybe a map I
think we need a black light for oh it's
just a skylight to open lovely MJ
someone cut a hole in a skylight I'm
gonna check it out
so while hammerheads guys were trying to
break in the front someone else lived in
through the roof looks that way
no sign of anyone at all shouldn't there
be guards here at night yeah maybe check
the security booth near the entrance
there should be cameras there too they
would have seen whoever broke in she's a
clever sausage isn't she I would have
never have thought about looking bad she
is darling just kick it in
the security booth secured I need a palm
print to get in any clue about what
happened to the guards will be inside is
there a way to override the lock without
a guards hand actually their handprint
yes the guards maybe you can lift prints
from the things they touched will you
mean to g-guard good idea always happy
to lend a hand I wonder if there's a
print on here limit its gun with it's
got a hand print well a part of one
partial handprint looks like I'll need
more we need two more by the looks of
its weird what's that it's like the
guards just vanished
always the flush like that a flashlight
I can get a part looks like that's a bit
difference vitamin tender ground another
one cool one more needed I believe God
wouldn't leave their stuff around like
this dream over entirely where's the
last one no Botox prints let's get your
arse prints
oh no no magazine there's a printer in
here just need to find it that might
work
and I think 12 down should be kareoke
not kumquat wow wow no partials to
reconstruct a hand print 12 down was it
some of the students like karaoke damn
bro he knows his crossword puzzles I'm
impressed
let's put it in and hope that we don't
have to do another little minigame
because I don't really like them
I should be able to reconfigure the
scanner so it takes my
if i bypass the optic sensor i can guys
boom-shaka-laka rude boy and print now
[Music]
what's inside I don't want to go in it's
gonna be a cutscene where he is not nice
what do you see they're alive beep dead
beep looks like they were tranquilized
where's the Steve I stronger teabag
Watson definitely not hammerhead style
finest even hammerhead
if they're a camera feed
let me check us there's a camera feed
Security office someone switched off
camera five well that's suspicious let
me turn it back on and see what they
didn't want anyone looking at it's
pointing at one of the paintings in the
exhibit that'll be the Maria has to be
the Maria I just said no one's stolen it
yet I need to see this up close figure
out what's so special about it
okey dokey the Maria is a brilliant
example of modern pastoral Impressionism
the saga of its repeated theft and
recovery are almost as intriguing as the
artwork itself looks like a pretty
normal painting to me it is there's way
more valuable stuff in that museum so
why is the Maggio still worked up about
this painting
hang on MJ someone's coming
whoops don't get dropped
in fact he probably should have stayed
in there then he was protected by a
bulletproof glass and they couldn't
steal the painting keep an eye out
spider-man could still be here t
Mohicans here the last of the Mohicans
damn it got a lock behind security glass
hey tell Frank we're gonna need to break
out the big guns
yeah tell Frank Frank knows everything
about the big guns
everyone knows the way out of here the
way they came in taking things the
taking things okay so those arrows mean
someone's stealing ours when we need to
protect the museum how do we get it
safely off him kick him in the face kick
him in the face and just hope he doesn't
drop the arts yeah nice complete silence
you're next you're next come on do it
drop the art oh you kept all of it I'm
gonna have to replay that the guy could
not tell and he kept a hold of the art
so didn't smash what a guy stop trying
to steal things it's not nice stop a
really bad break my ring endure
you're a bugger is that them all you the
last one right that's your chance honest
to the super sorry we're modern - where
did you go excuse me sir
weaponry in those not a good choice
right fella you're the last one you will
be set free I think I got them all hi MJ
not hard to put back though what about
the Maria this could have all been a
distraction my thoughts exactly
it's fine I'll head back there there's
nothing wrong with it the glass was
thick enough it's fine security walls
intact and bulletproof nobody's getting
near the Maria anytime soon mission
accomplished then yeah we all knew was
gonna happen
soon as he said that oh my word Felicia
I'm gonna have to call you right back
Nihao what's going on yeah turn off MJ
you look good been working out Oh I mean
you know a little high you swinging so
low now you're back with your ex a lot
of questions I'm just curious
yeah here that's bad for cats I bet you
tell me why you're really here I was
just waiting for the right moment look
behind you
oh good bazookas let's just let's just
bring rocket launchers into a museum
how'd you do right she'll steal the
painting and we'll fight come on what
the fridge magnets so much health I'm
actually a little bit petrified here
definitely a rocket launcher guys down
first we've cleared them let's work on
the big lat
and I doubt any more rockets yes No
where's it rocket no one else run away
run away time to run away alright
welcome go back in again we can go back
now we got help we know how to judge
no more rockets rocket man down oh let's
go bowling and eco wanna go bowling
see the last one how shall we finish him
why did you have to punch me dude now
look at yourself so satisfying
I can't tell enough how much this is and
I'm tired of your old ones
what you gonna stop stealing art what's
in the picture she's gonna show us
what's in the picture what are you doing
no memories take a cue of life I say
again oh but guys are trying to kill us
we have to save them
what where'd you go Peter is everything
okay sorry MJ I just ran into an old
friend sorry MJ he'll trouble yeah I ran
into my old girlfriend who I like more
than you the well-dressed these thugs
I like their jackets oh I love Cavalry's
here
whoa that went a bit bunny funny ha-ha
funny peculiar to see more accurate with
weapons than the other enemies do in the
base game or combo good luck good
delivery truck hope it's those new
slippers I ordered oh it's a big lad
what minigun severs yeah whoa you can't
rip it out of his grip and it's very
damn hard I looks like though he hits
his own friends and he's solid as a rock
come on lads
oh my word I like this new enemy type or
do I jump boy
come on feel like I really fighting you
forever
oh no one else one health one health
make it matter it counts was it childish
gambino
we did it - in the film time off if I
talk you won't if you don't get the
white chick she told us to come down in
your mix and noise sucker bait and I'm
the sucker where'd you meet her bodega
oh Waverly it's a real thing - bodega
and Weatherly Waverly it's a real place
MJ Stevie's really oh shoot that was a
destroy lookie legit is here set it up
to draw police away from stuff to the
car it's pretty damn cool Waverly
Cicero's I think maybe I can still catch
her Felicia takes her time she's no no
we can't do anything to him he is
permanent anyway that like that I like
it when the cutscenes link into actually
what's happening in the real world or
the digital world anyway let's go find
the John bodega
[Music]
there's the bodega all right Felicia
where are you
where you at Felicia whoa were you a
platypus look at those bills bills the
feet cold and all
there's our stake out here I'll tell all
the feet are cold on a bird what were
you looking at Felicia sidetracked
ignore me ignore me what were you
looking at a lady friend oh it's a bass
game so you need to go straight down the
middle it's always straight down the
middle the first time you play there she
is
that's good say hello my little point
[Music]
she knows judo oh hey spider Felicia
hamaji are no joke you shouldn't be
playing with the AH but I like to play
stick around oh I know the one of the
big labs badly time pleasures for these
in Mohicans that's what I'm going to
remember this first DLC for and cheap
Adidas tracksuit
right big labs going down oh one elf
this is where we start to play Oh down
close over survival of the fittest
we get out of this place we can throw
these count me if I remember rightly we
stick around crush the joint Buddha
Buddha man I like watching you
like watching you reminds me of old
times what's on that drive not entirely
sure to be honest
then why are you stealing it if I don't
they'll kill my son soon Wow what son
your son son I call BS Felicia has a son
can't be I mean it could be and I could
be no no no I'm not gonna think about
that right yeah you could be you could
be daddy spider-man
spider dad got away how methodical of
her she stole another day two drugs
so each family has a drive well not much
okay so what have you stolen now Felicia
have you done this time
cops have blocked off the whole street
if I can pick up the cat's trail maybe I
can catch up to her looks like the
security guard was hurt
maybe the EMT can tell me what happens
go for a Chapman hello that friend what
happened here
spider-man look at me when I've someone
stole a rare book or something is the
guard gonna be okay pretty bad case of
photokeratitis basically a flash burn of
his corneas so he'll recover
photokeratitis we've learned some today
some carrots do help us see in the dark
all you'll get photokeratitis 1ds
magnesium flare you probably what burn
that guards eyes if I analyze the
residue I can track her exactly what I
was going to say got it soldered done it
good there's the trail let's see where
it leads let's follow her Lady stench
having a hard time focusing I can't be a
dad I mean technically I can be but
looks like a member of the Macchio crime
family spider-man you're not gonna be a
spider dad she's tricking you it's what
she does every time and you always fall
for it just like these guys think they
can win a fight his brothers
Kayode for acting exactly like this like
I told the Cicero guys I do not work for
hammerhead I'm kind of insulted that you
would even think that we going to have
to fight the tall doesn't know
everything okay we got to finish you do
anymore for anymore
[Music]
good apologies for the animal sauce
[ __ ] one-liners
that's a nice wall out eat your heart
out Andy Warhol get back on the trail
right follow the lady stench
those look like hammer heads guys
MJ sending you a pic of a plate I need
you to run got it I'll let you know what
I find you get it yeah get it
uh hell where's the drive she said she
wanted to liver to hammerhead personally
didn't I tell you to get the drive yeah
but she gave the other ones to him so I
just figured so I tell you to do
something and you don't do it now you
know what happens next
wait wait wait wait wha so we have to
save one they would have killed us
it's actually a legit fight this time or
there's a big lab there's a big lab this
is a real fight dude who a first edition
of the King James Bible great here
fellas it's probably over do know how I
said something like a little bit of
light reading before bed okay you're
funnier than me okay so I think I know
what's on those drives years ago the
families agreed to a joint accounting
database in order to keep the peace put
all their assets in one place require
all five data drives to access it so
hammerhead steals Black Cats son and
then forces her to steal the drive so he
can steal the assets from the other
families hammerheads trying to get rich
quick and bankrupt the other families in
the process
we have to find that last drive before
he does okay so all the families want
the five sticks so they can control each
of his income something like that hey
Felicia
Alicia We Need to Talk oh I do miss our
little chats but I've got a run become a
lecture oh no
she's shorted out my web-shooters with
an EMP guess I'm doing this the
old-fashioned way
we're doing this the pizza pothole way
come on I want to help
[Music]
if hammer hits got your son can't do
this alone
why not I've done everything else alone
I'm saying you don't have to
why won't you trust mine let me hit up
get her before answered your own
question didn't you
Felicia what didn't company with this
because it's not your problem mine and
I'll handle it
maybe I don't think it's a problem wait
unless you mean the gang war I can take
care of myself do this ah judo throw it
you silly program
it's a bit dense isn't he this guy did
she jump that far web shooters are back
online I'm behind you I'm behind no
killing no breaking the law your way
won't get it done
[Music]
is like the electro way police you
remember the electro bit from the base
game we had to chase him around
I just want to talk let go all night if
that's what it takes
by a pet
we're still with you darling guess I
gotta play harder to get
as you get closer last time don't look
for me
where are you going what do we need to
do
Oh laughter I said I wanted to slow
black cat down so raps are gonna spray a
load all over
- yes stop running I have to chase you
the game says so
Spray it didn't get with any okay I know
your route now I know we are going to go
next
cuz I'm trying to find out oh good shot
look give you them
my turn
[Music]
come on she's gonna hurt you brother it
hurts me maybe it's me more than it
hurts you
I'm really soft come eat come on don't
catch up to nice you too nice betta now
can we talk like human beings
upside-down kiss this feels pretty human
to me I know what's on those drives
you're stealing look at you
brawn and brains you can't give
hammerhead the last Drive once he has
what he wants your son will just be a
loose end yeah yo dumped you like he
exists what are you thinking
stall him give us some time to find your
son I missed you
glad we're back together again not like
that shame okay I can probably give us a
couple days max so about your son he
doesn't exist chance I'm later for now
let's find him when he's safe
we can talk about that
mary-jane would be a lovely antique keep
in touch spider
oh I'm J's gonna kill me nah she's not
she's not right you just found out you
might be a dad you're trying to save
your son and you're stopping for pizza I
love you I love you too mate but now I
must destroy you all right okay that's
that's the best chat-up line I've heard
today
hey I followed up on that license plate
it's registered to a storage company
owned by one of hammerheads old friends
and they're now in the meantime I'll
just take a quick look around oh we're
going to do an MJ mission they're a bit
slow but they're there okay first things
first
news flash find a way into the common
lounge safely no this what we need to do
we need to do something jaywalking hey
I'm jaywalking here get an eyeful of
this strut your stuff Peter may have
super-strength
but can he shift a pallet like this girl
can I think not
or do you think of these type of
missions do you like the slow-paced ones
or did you find them a frustration after
being a superhero now to be a normal
person but she does have a stun gun to
go with a stupid Mohican haircut
counterfeit oh yeah that's kind of new
how do I do that stun gun stun gun his
backside oh my gosh did you see his head
hit that oh dude I'm so sorry I should
get a picture of that guy not building
I'll see if my contacts on the force can
positively ID him
well David this damn phone get back to
work no more slacking off I'm guarding
laptop golden opportunity good thing she
talks to herself shipping manifest this
could lead to their distribution center
and she's trying to be stealthy but she
needs to tell is he seeing so she has to
talk to itself say no I'm talking to
myself right now the cost of families
causing trouble acting like they want to
go to war
I gotta have a sit-down should we do
about this we're on high alert you see
anyone don't take any chances
take them out
okay you heard what he said I know the
shipping company take out everyone we
see you tell us where they're keeping
her son get out of here
quietly come on with a ginger ninja Oh
fun there's some money of course of
course we have to do this he's like a
nineties rap video you ready make it
rain we track the boxes I'm scared of
the boxes stagger
[Music]
I think I found statement I'm had enough
Mary Jane's two other good thanks Mary
Jane sorry sorry sorry what are you
doing here yeah you called us why do you
smell like pizza because I just ate
pizza well while you were out enjoying
lunch I was gathering evidence and
trying to find a missing child I ate his
fat I could I'm gonna have to follow up
on what call you later
Oh note to self no upside down he's
after double pepperoni Thanks
hey Felicia so what are we looking at
got a tip from an old friend hammerheads
keeping something extremely valuable in
that office above the bar lot of guys in
there if they spot me my son's dead
you'll make believe sons dead I'll draw
them out then you sneak in my hero come
on please
[Music]
right can we take any out before they
notice us I think they're all in twos or
threes anybody on their own they want to
make pinata club oh that guy safe
Kenyatta number one if nobody noticed
that come off it
or signal pinata number two
they're always in sight to one another
let's have some fun it's dead because I
don't use the the different apps apps
were they gadgets that's the word I'm
looking for I don't use the different
gadgets that he has on offer so we could
use a couple now I suppose we got impact
well what do you think about working
with the cat yeah she's joining in
Felicia
let's do that what deaf right you need
to take him out as quick as possible
that gun for hit son you're dead in your
face right he's gone that's good
we can fight now
I'll break your friggin jaw
I'll break your friggin you are without
finishes for days fall fine maybe some
reason it feels better fighting with
someone do you think a game like this
was working co-op I think it would one
left let's play with him Felicia do you
wanna go
this is lame live we don't swing a punch
she can live no man why did you do it
Oh Felicia its him with the hurricanrana
can you believe that your first spider
tags in the spider
and he's down for the count new tag-team
world champions he sons he something
gonna be killed so y'all getting drinks
see this is why I don't believe for a
second that she has a child she's too
nonchalant like why would why would you
get some champagne you wouldn't would
you did you find the location of the
vault and if you thought you were a dad
you wouldn't stand for any of this [ __ ]
we're narrowing it down and it's
definitely where he's keeping my son yes
speaking of him there's an overdue
conversation do you ever miss this what
me getting shot at while you steal
things I really tried going straight got
a job that didn't involve breaking or
entering even started wearing sweatpants
on weekends I wondered where you went
must have been hard for you especially
for the child
[Music]
we'll see you in five minutes then I
presume I need to go to that minutes
later I'm gonna find out
let me help if we're supposed to be
working together some things I do better
alone some things
I'll call you if I need an extra pair of
hands how can you resist her honestly
MJ nailed it this place is isolated they
could keep the kid here for weeks
without anyone noticing this is the
place I know it if they spot us it's
over we need to take them all out like
we used to
quiet as a cat sneaky as a spider as
loud as a grenade if they spot us they
might kill your son lucky he has to do
this hell I only take out enemies
stealthily her current target is marked
with a pussycat
there's no pussycat on the screen I
supposed to see a pussycat of protection
my fault right on the d-pad and she will
take them out oh this is gonna be cool
this is gonna be good all right how many
we got to find 18 enemies without being
spotted we can't go any higher
somebody can see us flick help maybe a
lot of guys guarding this place this
won't be easy
this'll be fun though right we'll take
this knife is out first
sweep it off still using that technique
can you see
this guy yep
very nice oh I like this I like the one
can ship this is awesome buddy literally
didn't see that coming the team left
Rocky 12 left three together this is
going to be a little bit difficult keep
with the snippers there goes that Wesley
Snipes
split those guys up oh of course yeah I
can do the throat thing no
there's no safe yeah yeah you get that
one going in no I'm good this one looks
like about nine guys let's see what it
makes the dream work
so he's taught
if he's going there then the other one
must be on his Todd is the other one gun
know who can see him go for it flick oh
oh it's been spotted hey nice one that's
what I'm here for a little bit a little
bit Felicia I lack you in love I'll a
couple done
go guys over here we've been spotted
salted mine out got yours Felicia I
might be able to split them up
[Music]
[Applause]
just give the word spider yeah take him
just a few left there's these two
they're chatting they're like three feet
whoa they're like three feet apart
wonder
better investigate take yo conflicts all
yours this is by far the most fun I've
had on this DLC no we shouldn't piss
about it's gonna suggest doing something
stupid but I quite like the stealth it
sounds like the boss is worried about
you oh we could hope no what do you
think is gone flake you wanna go first
or second which one D wants she wants
that one that was so cool really really
enjoyable
yeah we need coop stealth games that's
all we need
that's a places to hide a vault around
here
you check the shipping containers while
I check in that building over there
Felicia what I'm sorry hammerhead did
this to you
yeah well he's about to find out he mess
with the cat you get the clown Judah
Klaus
shipping containers should check out
those shipping containers I feel this is
a ruse
I'm behind door number one thing
supplies gone no kid nothing number two
pianos pianos brand nothing Donna that's
not a doll and the next exit that door
number three has just a bunch of Graces
better keep looking better keep looking
I'm finally doing them before we have
saberling guns what is this stuff whoa
hammerheads got sable weapons I wonder
what else he has oh we haven't fought
some Sables equipment for a while
and that answers that question let's do
news hammer hit thugs and stable weapons
long as the big gloves - oh they were
fine oh we need to take out that laser
to gun on this a PCS rocket launchers
minigun - mini guns this is not going
well
Felicia Palooza
is three left to left one left dude you
can leave if you want just leave your
weapon here no you had a chance they
never run they should run more often and
that's it okay time to find Felicia
right Felicia do I have to find she was
heading into the entrance she doesn't
use print dolls does he walking in the
door Felicia default this is a giraffe
this must be a trap Felicia
no no you've been tricked again gotta be
kidding me
tell me you were just stringing me along
sorry sweetie but I needed help to pull
off a job this big all you ever wanted
was hammerheads drive the entire wealth
of the Mafia in the palm of my hand
you keep hammerhead fake drives you
think he's gonna be mad at me hemorrhoid
hey know how my head so the kidnapping
did your son it was all just a lie lie
is such an ugly word miss misdirection I
prefer misdirection oh yes I knew she'd
bring that line right gang take the
drive to the police hey I earned these
besides hammerheads on a mission and
nothing is gonna stop him if anything I
just help slow him down a bit clean up
the whole yard check the ball time to go
I'll raise a glass to you on the Riviera
Felicia
Vasia
tami girl and also bang girl boss we're
in drives gone there's a tracker on that
drive find her and kill her and if she's
dumb enough to go to a little penthouse
I've got a crew wait medicine tits
sky-high what about the drives I don't
care about the drives I just want it
dead
got it we'll find her if there's a
tracker on that drive Felicia's trouble
gotta get to her fast come on cuz we
dense and we help her all the time
even though she tricks hammerhead knows
where you are and he's going to kill you
there's a tracker on his drive I don't
get you spider
I just calm the hell out of you and here
you are trying to save me how can you be
so damn nice all the time it's Dennis
it's not about being nice it's about
doing the right thing you've got so many
talents I wish you'd use them to help
someone other than yourself yeah well
you should know by now that's not how I
roll you can change Felicia love you
spider I'll miss you wait your penthouse
he's rigged it to explode don't worry I
still got all nine lives
dear mate what do you think he
spider-man a pushover are you just doing
the right thing
got a move
come on
the epic music going on it's dark music
something's Bad's gonna happen
don't do it Felicia
[Music]
right revenge is a revenge mission now
we're going to kill them all
especially hemorrhoid head himself to be
continued no your son of a beech okay
alright I get it
I quite like that I really enjoyed that
actually so I took it took me just over
two hours to do this so I'll probably
cut this down to less than an hour if I
can yeah it's alright there's lots of
side missions to do and I'll probably
not include the missions we've screwball
or the pickup the paintings missions
these are a little side quests that you
can do just adds to what you're already
doing but yeah I really enjoyed that
I'll definitely come back again for part
two of the DLC and should we just stick
around just in case there's an end scene
there's always an end credits scene
isn't there let's see if it's here Wow
and they still haven't found a body no
do you think she's survived
I don't know anything's possible but so
how's it feel to not be a dad
no no I'm serious honestly yeah yeah
I've kind of relieved yeah I've got a
lot going on yeah you do
but I think you're gonna be an amazing
dad someday at the right time with the
right person
Oh in that right noise is that it that's
it yes
follow the money complete
congratulations you have finished the
high story the adventure continues in
the next chapter turf wars so what do
you think that was DLC one I really
enjoyed it
I imagine from PlayStation grenades I'll
see you next time
[Music]